the left has become
militant
this is true
in the u.s military where the woke
leadership of the pentagon is pushing
this stuff this is true throughout
corporate america this is true
throughout the government this is true
on our own website uh last night we
premiered matt walsh's documentary what
is a woman taking on the transgender
agenda
and this was
this was a direct shot at the cultural
left on the first day of pride month and
we knew it was going to be the biggest
subscription event of the year this was
the biggest
most ambitious expensive movie we've put
out there
matt flew to freaking africa to find the
answer to this question what is a woman
and some people who signed up to watch
it may have found that they had some
trouble at least for 15 minutes 20
minutes
we took a look at what was going on why
is the site down why isn't this working
we've now confirmed the daily wire came
under a sustained and significant ddos
attack
so
there was
some group
some individual or some group or some
group of groups
targeted the daily wire website
with a very sophisticated attack because
they didn't want you to see the premiere
of what is a woman because they're so
afraid of this one question that
deflates the entire transgender ideology
people don't want you to see this movie
okay they want to silence us they want
to shut us down and it's too bad for
them because this was the largest
premier event we've ever had in the
history of the daily wire we got lots
and lots of new members more new members
than on any single day ever in the
history of this company and if you want
to watch it if you want to become one of
those members
go to what is a woman dot com
we really need you to support this
you can you can see it now when we talk
about the military
the corporations especially
finance
the daily wire is a pretty big company
started out in jeremy's pool house now
we've got lots and lots of employees and
a lot of money coming in and lots of
projects being pushed out
we have not taken money
from
private equity from
any of the ways that you can raise money
we have not taken money yet because very
often
when you raise money in that way
it comes with a lot of strings you've
got to kowtow to certain woke rules to
the esg rules environmental social and
governance policies you lose your soul
as a company when you take that kind of
money so we have always relied on our
listeners and
you guys have been so great and
subscribed and supported it and so
that's how we can produce this content
we need more of you to do that if you
want us to keep producing this kind of
content that gets the libs so upset that
they target us with ddos attacks if you
want to keep keep this kind of content
coming at the moment that it matters
right at the start of pride month when
we're going to be living in just one
giant rainbow for the next 29 days
you've got to subscribe so you go to
whatisawoman.com
right now
you will get 25
off a new membership thank you for doing
that i'm glad you like that clip now
ring
ding subscribe listen guys this is pride
month okay
i don't know what that has to do with
anything but come on all right this is
when we've got to get serious you got to
be inclusive you've got to be diverse
you've got to open your mind to lots of
new opinions and notifications ring ding
subscribe do what you got to do apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
subscribe there as well to the michael
knowles show we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]